President Biden is in Mexico City this
morning for a summit with the leaders of
Canada and Mexico the big issue is the
immigration crisis and yesterday Mr
Biden made his first stop at the U.S
Mexico border since taking office weisha
Zhang is traveling with the president
and has more on this part of the story
weisha good morning to you
good morning to you Gail and good
morning to everybody President Biden
came here after spending several hours
in El Paso Texas home to one of the
busiest ports of Entry Republicans are
blaming him for the record number of
people who are crossing illegally over
to the U.S and Blasting that visit as
nothing more than a photo op
President Biden met with workers at a
center for migrant Services Sunday who
told him they need more aid from the
federal government they need a lot of
resources we're going to get them for
him earlier Republican Governor Greg
Abbott welcomed the president to Texas
then criticized him for not coming
sooner it just so happens he's two years
at about 20 billion dollars too late
Abbott said as much in a letter he
handed the president on the tarmac
here's the deal he's never called me to
talk to me about the immigration issue
now I provided him a letter that
provides a tangible Concrete Solutions
that will stop illegal immigration also
in the letter Abbott blamed Mr Biden
this chaos is the direct result of your
failure to enforce the immigration laws
that congress enacted
last week President Biden announced new
restrictions on migrants seeking Asylum
amid growing pressure from both
Republicans and Democrats the new
policies expand the trump-era covet ban
known as title 42 although the
administration will also offer more
legal Pathways for migrants from Haiti
Nicaragua and Cuba people are not
processed and are so they just hear and
they don't know what what the options
are they don't have any options
at Sacred Heart Catholic Church hundreds
of migrants sought help like this mother
and her five-year-old son from El
Salvador she begged President Biden for
an opportunity to work in the U.S
and she said it's not easy but knows
it's not impossible
President Biden did not visit any of
those areas where migrants have been
camping out nor did he see any large
groups arriving something that his
critics have been very quick to point
out immigration is sure to come up when
the president has a bilateral meeting
with his Mexican counterpart later today
Nate
we just yank in Mexico City thank you so
much but